[Music]
we do not dominate the market for
launching communication satellites we
created systems for our national
security and our military power that are
recognized as as being critical to the
u.s. posture in the world and so I think
we are poised in the last couple of
years of this century to be in a leading
if not dominant position in what happens
in the world with respect to space in
the in the years to come
not a bad heritage but the times they
are a-changin this most of this is a
cliche for you but but we're saying that
that with the end of the Cold War in the
space race the notion that you could
measure the value of the civilian space
program by whether it was ahead or
behind the Soviet Union obviously has
gone away we're not behind anybody in
any significant way we don't need to
look with big systems at the Eurasian
landmass to understand preparations or
lack of preparations for a conflict on
the central front and Europe nor do we
have to count Soviet ICBMs so the
requirements for our strategic
intelligence systems are very different
the kind of military engagements that
we're going to likely be involved in and
are involved in around the world are
rather different and that puts different
requirements on 21st century space
capabilities we have learned that that
for the kind of warfighting that we are
likely to engage in we mean the United
States through most of this that that
space systems are increasingly important
and
the ones we have are not very well
matched to the requirements so there's a
kind of secular change underway in in in
military space policy is that graph a
couple of times ago suggested
communicating via satellites is an
integral part of the explosion of
information systems in the world until
1971 and only a few of us in this room
can remember that far back but but some
of us can it was formally not legal to
use communication satellites to
communicate inside the United States
they were only international systems it
was a deregulation of the US market that
started the growth that that that is
exploded in the 80s and 90s of national
and regional communication satellite
systems and has led to things like Intel
sat and Inmarsat global
quasi-governmental organizations
becoming obsolete they essentially are
no longer needed to manage global
communication systems and are being
broken up a variety of communication
applications from geo plus the the rapid
expansion of mobile communications and
maybe maybe there is a business in high
resolution one to 10 meter imagery on a
commercial basis we'll see so what's
going on this is my segue into the
future and I'm going to talk about each
of these separately the big growth
sector is commercial space 20% growth a
year in in by some measure of revenue
and most of that growth is in
telecommunications the National
Reconnaissance Office is no weaker than
it used to be it's now acknowledged it's
rethinking what its role should be in
the world of the 21st century
and it's changing away from almost total
dependence on very large very expensive
systems to small distributed kind of
very capable satellites any of you see a
recent broadcast on CBS Evening News
where the cameras were allowed in the
cleanroom in the Lockheed Martin plant
in in Denver and the Hughes plant in El
Segundo where key elements of these
systems were shown for the first time
not with much explanation but the notion
you could put on the evening news these
large systems Aviation week says the
biggest system was lacrosse radar
satellite since I don't have access to
that kind of information I can report
what Aviation Week says and not verify
whether it's correct or not
sheila widnall back here now on the
faculty was Secretary of the Air Force
when the Air Force created this vision
of a transition over the next decade or
two from an Air Force to an air in space
force and after that to a space and Air
Force so that the the role of space in
in that segment of military operations
is is is under transition I'll spend a
fair amount of time since this is a NASA
space grant talk talking about NASA with
the word reinvention becoming a cliche
and things are merging the the the
jargon word for what has characterized
the past 40 years as stovepipes
everything in in inside its own
compartment with very little cross
compartment fertilization and I think
that that's changing some cross sector
cooperation increasing maybe not as much
as is it would be nice to see alright
let's talk a bit about commercial
by some measures unfortunately not the
ones somebody in Lockheed Martin these
are Lockheed Martin slides if if you
have logo recognition somebody in in
their public relations office has to
change this phrase what is commercial
space commerce that's not very
euphonious but you see the growth
eighty-six three point two billion
dollars a year ninety one eleven point
five ninety six twenty six point seven
and a projected fifty seven point five
so that in fourteen or fifteen years
that's from three billion to fifty seven
billion dollars a year of activity not
related to government space programs and
and you see most of that is the services
routed through satellites not the
building of the hardware was it here
it's about fifty fifty services and
hardware satellites launches and you see
it's the non glamorous ground equipment
which is a large portion of this market
rapidly growing a kind of market to the
point where by some measures the
revenues associated with a commercial
sector are larger than the money that
governments are beans but be putting
into space what is driving this is
primarily the growth in various types of
communication satellites there's an
analytic group in the Washington area
called the teal group and each year they
put out a projection of how many
satellites will be launched in the next
five years and you see their growth in
in five-year projections over the past
six years from 650 to over 2000
satellites fundamentally only the most
visionary of people anticipated five
years ago the rapid growth
in low-earth orbit of mobile
communications nobody thought about
telev D six or five years ago I guess
iridium was just getting funded just
getting started but this this growth in
communication by satellites for multiple
purposes is something that's kind of
snuck up on people if you were in at the
start you have the potential not to
certainty of making a lot of money today
it's mainly geostationary satellites for
voice television and Direct TV and some
data tomorrow but tomorrow is coming
real fast we were talking at lunch that
iridium which is the first of the mobile
communication satellites mainly for
lawyers you know it's three dollars a
minute I think is what they're billing
rate is and a fairly large it's it's
people who have to be connected wherever
they are in the world so that they can
do business they're supposed to turn
their system on in September of this
year
this is a Motorola venture global star
which is larell is close behind that
ellipse oh and Aiko is a system spun off
from Inmarsat and you know I'm at least
most of you can read this and in the
years to come it is this this wideband
high data rate ka BAM systems which
essentially are going to put Internet in
space that are the real growth area so
it's a different form of satellite
communication the optimist and the
market look at numbers like this and say
you know still less than a third of the
people in the world have access to
telephones at all I mean the this blue
is the percent of people in the world
without access to any kind of of
telecommunication system and say we're
gonna make money filling that you know
and if if they're right the future may
look something like this this is a
French colleague of mine named Ellen
PAH developed this chart a few years ago
here's Apollo with a peak in 65 of the
money spent on on science tech splurge
and human spaceflight kind of leveled
out here's a later wave of space
development as military systems became
useful but again kind of stabilized and
levelled out and here's his projection
with a growth of information-based space
systems and if anything like that
happens that is what's going to drive
the future in space not coined Mars or
well anything else there is a derivative
commercial space market which is a
launch this very controversial area of
what kind what is the launch market this
is one figure that some colleagues at
Boeing worked out that that says that
over the next 10 years 60% of the
satellite market doesn't have a launch
vehicle assigned to it yet which again
if you're in the launch vehicle business
you say aha market opportunity and there
are lots of organizations trying to
capitalize on that market opportunity
same people projects something like this
that in the past decade the u.s. because
of taking the shuttle out of the
commercial market and the slow startup
of Atlas and Delta as commercial
launchers seeded a launch market
primarily to Ariane but also to proton
and long march systems that it's are
going to be a much more internationally
competitive market in the next decade
this is I guess large communication
satellites primarily to geo rather than
the smaller launches how many of those
are American systems do we care
I mean sure Delta is an Atlas is but
Atlas's co marketed by Lockheed Martin
through the International Launch System
subsidiary with proton so a lot of the
profits from proton launches go to
Lockheed Martin Sea Launch is a joint
venture of Boeing Ukrainian rocket
manufacturer and a Norwegian drilling
platform manufacturer so that the us one
way or another is in about 70% or so
it's only long march Ariane and h2 a h2
a is a paper rocket the Japanese are
trying to take their existing launch
vehicle and cut its costs in half which
the engineers in this crab should know
is a pretty good trick to take an
existing design and reduce its cost by
50% are there other areas for future
commercial growth I'll come back to some
of this but but some of these over the
next 20 or 25 years will probably hit
become sectors of high economic
potential I'm told that the major
application of what's now called GPS
Global Positioning satellites it's
probably going to be the timing precise
timing for things like computer systems
around the world rather than the
navigation applications and sometimes
somewhere down the line projection the
US Air Force is going to get out of the
business of providing that for free and
somebody else is going to provide it for
a cost sometime remote sensing a lot of
talk about commercializing low-earth
orbit if dr. young is right and ten
years after Space Station is up there
will forget how much it cost and
concentrate on how much it's done we
will have industrial parks and and and
private space platforms and and lots of
industrial activity in in low-earth
orbit nASA released a report
with a private association last week on
the potential space tourism and I'll
come back to a couple of the others of
these I'm not in any way expert in in
the role of space-based intelligence
systems so this is kind of derivative
but I I wanted to make some comments on
it as part of this overview there is a
stated goal in for the United States of
our security depending on our
information dominance or superiority our
security planning for the future assumes
that we will have better information
than any potential adversary and young
people in here probably don't want to
even think about a world in which
they're nasty people out there wanting
to do us harm those of us that are old
enough to have lived through periods
where there were nasty people out there
wanting to do his harm to say that it
would be nice if we lived in a world
where we didn't have to do any of this
but that's not the world we currently
live in NRO continues to push the
technological frontier and continues to
develop very advanced systems to carry
out its missions we're at the point of
taking the imagery that formerly was
only available to the President and
people with very high clearances and
that was one of the problems in the in
the Gulf War and developing ways of
putting that imagery into a fighter
cockpit on a real-time basis so a guy
going out to fly a sortie has some sense
of the best information available this
this over here isn't is not exactly NRO
but it suggests for the Bosnia conflict
how we're using our space systems
National Security Agency and pick this
is old it's now the National NEMA
National imagery and mapping agency
which
hates the the images from NRO satellites
Defense Intelligence Agency CIA etc
putting their information into various
state side based systems which are
communicated via commercial satellite
and into the bosnian theater plus some
real-time work and again you can't quite
see but that's an Intel Sat satellite
with a secure internet channel on it
real-time data feeds going through a
system in England but out to the
commander and the frontline in Bosnia
and again that that's the kind of hookup
between the national security and
military sectors I think more and more
is going to happen again it's it's not
done with any publicity but the imagery
that NRO satellites collect is made
available for environmental for disaster
warning disaster relief and humanitarian
applications so there's this cross
sector work of using the capabilities
that are available and again here's
another nice typo hopefully they're not
multiple proliferations and I hope
that's not a prediction and the advanced
technology coming out of nron and I
should say other military and strategic
defense initiative programs are flowing
particularly in the commercial use and
some of the advanced technology coming
out of the commercial sector is flowing
in into military use
I should have something in here that
talks about the military so I must have
lost a slide along the way imagine
there's one there here's the kind of
stuff that the the straight-line
military is is talking about these days
is recognizing that space systems
operate and are important about on the
full spectrum of activities related to
u.s. security at one end economic power
and the other strategic nuclear conflict
with I like this it's kind of new
acronym to me oo TW operations other
than war humanitarian natural disaster
assistance terrorism peacekeeping
unconventional warfare minor
conventional major conventional theater
nuclear strategic nuclear space
superiority supports the full spectrum
of operations it's a way of thinking
about the role of space in in in
military thinking and military strategy
that I think has not been very common in
the past one of the emerging alliances
there is the alliance between the
Department of Defense in the commercial
space industry where DoD is recognizing
that that the investments that
commercial space industry are making
gives all kinds of capabilities the
military can use without having to pay
for all of it and again you see these
are various Air Force and what's the
space and Missile Command slides the the
capabilities from commercial space
systems and this was mainly telecom that
that the military could take advantage
of so a lot of that fertilization going
on the buzzword in military space right
now is space control at what point and
how does the US military ensure that the
US has
total access to space for whatever
purposes it wants to use space for and
denies that similar capability to our
adversary that's that state that's
stated in military terms we can't do
that now or we don't do it now anyway at
some point we we according to the
military planners want to know what's
going on everywhere all the time in
space we want the ability to protect our
own assets prevent any damage to them
and negate the ability of others to use
space they MMD's national missile
defense using space systems for missile
defense which is SDI redux an integrated
command and control over all of this
that's of the systems to do this are not
in place the military doctrine to do it
is not in place the political will to do
it is not in place but if some aspects
of the military leadership and national
security community have their way they
will be in place and space the the
relationship between the military and
what goes on in space will be rather
different than the future then it has
been all right so I've taken 45 minutes
and haven't said anything about NASA
that's good it's good in a couple of
different ways
I made a flip comment at lunch today
that NASA's a sideshow and that's too
strong but the reality is that the
commercial national security and
military space sectors certainly taken
together overwhelming finance in level
of activity probably in technological
innovation what happened through NASA
what NASA does is get headlines and and
create in images and visions and those
are very important things for the future
today is an interesting day it's the
beginning of the seventh year of dan
Golden's tenure as nasa administrator
showed up April the first 1992 none of
us that met mr. golden as early weeks on
the job would have predicted he would
still be there seven years later but
there he is he is trying almost by force
of will
to change an institution with an immense
amount of inertia NASA learned a
particular pattern of success from the
Apollo program and maybe a different
pattern but equally high inertia in its
relationship with the scientific
community in how to do space science and
and changing that the pattern has been
very very difficult I think
Golden's changes are irreversible but
I'm not positive to that a lot of people
general people in polls when they're
asked about NASA's budget think it's
about the same as a Department of
Defense or Health and Human Services or
something like that it's useful once in
a while to show a chart like this this
is the relative size of the NASA budget
compared to other federal agencies and
and and most people I think don't have
this image in their mind because the
visibility of what NASA does that it is
the smallest budget of the major
agencies of government and it is smaller
than it was supposed to be when golden
got there in 92 the NASA budget that was
under debate in Congress at that time
anticipated by now fiscal 99 that the
budget request would be 21 billion
dollars
instead it's 13 and a half billion
dollars so there's been a downsizing if
you combine correcting for inflation
plus actual revenue loss of probably 35
percent of nasa's expected future you
see the actual budget hasn't come down
very much in in fiscal 90
five it was 14 or 15 I guess 15 billion
dollars and now it's around the 13
billion but there's been this falling
off of future expectations the budget I
think has stabilized this is the ninety
nine budget request out here and you see
it's flat for the next five years the
last year there was some budget politics
being played that we're NASA were
threatened with this two billion dollar
cut over the next couple of years but
that was never real and has now gone
away and and the budget is flat so I
think that the financial future of the
agency looks stable but that's not
growth that's stable
these are NASA propaganda slides
probably most of you have seen them the
revolution in the cost of spacecraft
from 592 hope 474 million dollars of
spacecraft the development time going
down from eight years to three years the
flight rate going up from two Science
Space past a year to fourteen a year
something like that is actually
happening the the change from the big
you know if you did this for Cassini it
would be even a higher number than this
but a two billion dollar lifecycle cost
for Galileo is is what a third more than
the lifecycle cost of nine planetary
missions there has clearly been a shift
in paradigm the science program now has
a theme origins which has gotten a I
think both scientifically and publicly a
lot of positive reaction the notion of
looking for earth-like planets in our
celestial neighborhood and studying the
birth and evolution of galaxies stars
and planets as the organizing theme for
the future this program OMB is fully
funded
gave NASA in its budget this year more
than it thought it was going to get in
the endless in the origins budget I
noticed when I got through putting
through these view graphs I managed to
do this without any image of Mars
interesting there is this new scientific
theme of ice draw astrobiology studying
the the origins evolution diffusion and
future of life in the universe including
the discoveries on earth of all the
places that that life appears there are
these fascinating images of the surface
of Europa that suggest a some sort of
liquid ocean under a frozen surface as a
place to go look for life caught times
attention now a couple of years ago you
can tell how old this was dole drops
Clinton Rises no comments this was the
first discovery of extrasolar planets a
discovery which i think is disputed by
the way this one but in front of time
somebody's judges that's of great
interest gene covert was complaining
about Hubble's discovery of the week but
here's a Hubble picture seeing of
galaxies filled and clearly the the
image of our place in the universe as an
organizing theme for space science has
provided a theme that that had been
missing for a long time
the Earth Science program I think is on
the way to being improved I'm not an
expert what used to be called mission
the planet Earth and has recently
changed recently been changed to earth
science if you wanted to plain
linguistics understanding the reason for
that change would be an interesting
thing to do but I don't have much to say
about it
there's an attempt to privatize
repetitive accurate operations like the
shuttle and an ongoing debate right now
of whether you might even bring the
shuttle back into use as a commercial
launch vehicle there's a big a couple
billion dollar contract competition for
s Fock space flight operations contract
is to run Mission Control and
communications and and and and that sort
of thing not a very clear strategy about
future technology and future launch
systems I think the country recognizes
that launch is in a really an important
area we don't have our act together on
launch and a couple things to say about
that in a moment
the central issue may be as always is
the future of humans in space of the
thirteen and a half billion dollar NASA
budget seven billion goes to in one form
or another to human spaceflight and and
and why is a continuing question current
focus is us got to proof this stuff is
the International Space Station and and
there's just the beginnings of the
serious debate of what's going to follow
the space station let's talk a couple
minutes about station
there it is in all its glory first
element launch is supposed to be this
summer even money whether it will
actually be that or not first two items
are ready the functional cargo block
which is back in the middle here built
by Russia paid for by the United States
and the the first connection node built
and paid for by the United States might
be a little clearer in this line drawing
which isn't quite as as nice but the
service module which is the Russian
component is behind schedule and there's
a decision next month of whether to wait
for it slip the initial launches or
substitute a u.s. thing called the
interim control module basic point is
the program is still in trouble it's
still not under managerial control or
budget control but it will happen it's
too late for us to say no we're not
going to do station why are we doing it
I'm not going to read all of these
reasons why leadership during the 90s
blah blah blah the the the only point is
the date of this slide is September of
1983 and the rationale hasn't changed
very much which is either good or bad my
own view is that that there is an
underpinning belief almost an article of
faith and the part of people that have
thought about it in the United States
that humans in space have value and
we've got to test that belief shuttle
isn't it shuttles a camping trip
shuttles you know goes up bad food
toilets don't work etc you can do some
stuff for some period of time but it's
not the kind of layer it was never
designed to be a laboratory to start out
with it was designed to be a
transportation system to a Space Station
finally we're gonna have the station I
think we can afford the task
and see whether there's things of value
I'm kind of a cautious optimist that the
answer will be yes and besides we have
to do the station before we do anything
else talking about going back to the
Moon or Mars is just I think idle talk
until the station experience is under
our belt what are the issues for the
future one is and maybe the a a or the
critical one is solving the
transportation cost problem this came
out of an Air Force study a couple of
years ago of the cost in millions of
dollars per launch this is the cost per
pound to orbit somewhere between $4,000
for the long march to 16 thousand
dollars a pound for the Titan shuttles
down around 10,000 a pound Ariane 5 they
hope somewhere in this range that's
still a lot of money you have to have
very valuable applications with a very
high probability of success to pay this
much for access to orbit we're at this
point the only country in the world
that's investing any significant money
in advanced space transportation and
we're not investing nearly enough to
solve the question of low how best to
lower the cost so we'll see where do we
go with people
what happens if station fails something
I don't want to even think about but it
certainly have a chilling effect on
humans in space for a significant amount
of time do we put people a lot of people
in low-earth orbit
here's an image that came out of the
NASA space Transportation Study let's
see if I can there's no up in space
except that you wouldn't be able to read
it so this is a zero-g space hotel with
private transportation systems and
probably some artificial gravity on some
part of it and zero-gravity on other
parts the the recently released study
says there is a big market for private
space travel mm-hmm what do you folks
think you're the ones that would be
paying for it do we is there anybody
here that thinks humans will never leave
Earth orbit and go beyond it
I wouldn't think so here so the question
only becomes when and and who does it
right so I you know I can I can put up
nice images these are I think synthesis
group images of a pretty large sized
lunar base and and field geology on Mars
and and those are the visions that a lot
of people still carry I'm not sure the
young people of the world carry them as
much as we their descendants the Apollo
generation but here's a view graph you
haven't seen yet it's a remember it's
only a view grid anybody want to get
hazard a guess of what that is it
well yeah except it's the North Pole of
the moon and here's a mirror catching
sunlight reflecting it down so you can
extract some water and you can then
build things around the edge so this is
a say NASA's latest sore Pat Rawlings
latest conceptual vision of a outpost to
take advantage of the discovery of
frozen water somewhere on the moon
maybe there's a chart here I like to use
you know it seems to me that that the
answer of whether people live leave this
planet for long periods of time depends
on these two questions can you use non
terrestrial materials to support people
and can you do something of economic
value only if the answer to that is both
of those are yes do you get full space
settlement if you answers
No then you might get Antarctic type
bases where everything has to be
exported and you do some science if you
can't make if you can't use local
resources you might also have some
tourists a la Antarctica and if you know
I'm sorry to read that wrong if you
can't use local resources then you
probably have to have robot minds to do
anything of economic value if you can
live off the land but no economic value
then you'll get tourism and research on
the assumption research has no economic
value you notice one other fancy view
graph coming out of the same people at
NASA and advanced studies this is this
is this year's concept of a solar power
satellite power tower and and there's
enough interest to
put some money in in the current NASA
budget to do some very limited
technology validation and to check the
economics both interesting things to do
you know if if if this were valid the
idea of producing large scale grid level
energy from space that could be the the
billion dollar application one of the
questions I have is whether things like
communication satellites have anything
anymore to do with space policy or are
they telecom systems that happen to be
in space that's what I mean by there
were normalizing integrating space
systems into larger human endeavors
Communications managing the earth
environmental policy
warfighting etc normalizing space I
think is going to be one of the major
trends of the 21st century for all of
the areas except NASA how much growth
potential there are in areas like this
remains I think to be seen do we know
what we're doing it was kind of the
bottom line question does the United
States have any kind of national
strategy for space I this is kind of
bootleg out of a briefing by the current
head of the European Space Agency making
an argument that Europe has to have a
space strategy and and his perception
Antonio rota is that the United States
has a clear policy of space leadership
I've been inside the beltway in
Washington for 31 years
I wouldn't know to where to go to find
that but again I think if you start
thinking about it and maybe go back to -
if I can find it one of these very early
view graphs this one
the united states fate faces a 21st
century in space it is making an immense
comparative investment in space
capability compared to any other nation
of the world their underpinning that is
some sense I think of national will and
priority that says for the United States
in this next century space is one of the
areas that we're going to be in and be
in a leadership position NASA is going
to be important to that in doing science
and doing exploration and providing some
of the technology that that will
underpin the rest of these activities
but space in the 21st century is much
much broader than just what we have been
used to seeing for the past 40 years it
should be an exciting time thank you
Thank You Jon and before opening the
Florida questions I'd like to present
you with the certificate of appreciation
for the message the Space Grant
consortium thank you
we are very grateful for that inspiring
lecture I would also like just a call to
the attention of the audience
three of the future lectures in the
Wednesday afternoon lecture series in
modern space science and engineering
which is held at three o'clock each
Wednesday in thirty seven to twelve that
are closely related to areas that John
brought up on the 15th of April two
weeks from today the subject will be
corona the those early spy satellites
that John referred to and we sell books
that will you know you if you'll send
what up a sense them up here we'll go on
we'll go and take orders the lecture
whom you know is Dow Smith yeah Gauss
Smith was one at Boston University one
of the founders of AI tech there's a
neighbor of mine in New Hampshire he
said he's been aching for decades to be
able to talk about this stuff so that
should that's on Wednesday the 15th the
following Wednesday the 22nd professor
sheila widnall of MIT back from her
duties the Secretary of the Air Force
we'll be talking about Air Force
leadership in space again picking up
some of John's views and then the
following Wednesday after Wednesday
after that the 29th professor Eric Jason
from Tufts University will be talking
about new sciences that's coming out of
the Hubble Space Telescope so among the
other lectures in that series those
three are particularly relevant to some
of the areas that dr. Langston has told
us about now I presume that you are
willing to take some questions I'm here
my planes 9:00 a.m. tomorrow morning
order of Issa where's all that money
going does that mean that France has a
robust military space program well I
think that first of all would attack
your premise that France is not a
support or supporter visa many people in
Europe think that that ISA is an
instrument for getting other countries
to pay for French priorities but the
current Minister overseeing the space
program in France Claude Alegre is a
committed scientist who doesn't think
that human spaceflight is worth very
little it doesn't think he's worth much
and they and it's not enamored with
ESA's performance there's a Gollust few
that space is connected to national
standing and national grandeur that is
pretty pervasive in France and has
historically been a reason for the
French space program to be so large plus
France has recognized that if Europe is
serious about becoming a entity called
Europe it has to have a security posture
as well as an economic posture and space
systems are important to that security
spot posture so France has taken the
lead in trying to create a European
security space capability so far with
two observation satellites called Helios
but with plans for the future so there's
some military but it's mainly for France
a political and scientific belief in the
importance of space
a subsidy that the French government
gives to Ariane question was what's the
subsidy for the French government for to
their Launch System Ariane well if you
could measure that you'd have a lot of
people in the United States happy
because then we could attack through
through the World Trade Organization the
the French subsidy you know one person's
subsidy is another person's its
assistance anyway what's the subsidy
that the US government is providing the
Lockheed Martin and Boeing to build
heavy lift commercial systems to compete
with the Ariane 5 in what used to be
known as the evolved expendable launch
vehicle program there's now Delta 4 and
whatever Lockheed Martin decides to call
its heavy lift vehicle the short form a
answer to your question is substantial
there is substantial government
assistance to those programs another
aspect I mean there is there's our
different classes of economic accounting
and and I'm pretty sure for example in
France that if there is a town that's
heavily dependent on the space business
they will subsidize to the extent that
it's cheaper to do the space business
and a loss and to put all these people
on unemployment compensation and and I
think that so that there are a number
it's it's not a black and white question
there are a lot of subtleties and we
don't keep space installations working
in the United States because of their
employment impacts right
I mean the cultures are so different and
then the relationship between the
government and private sector you know
so you could go on forever sir yeah
there's been a lot of talk recently
about these companies trying to get
started with space tourism and stuff
yeah are these people for in your
opinion are these for real and are we
going to see something in the next you
know 10 years or something like that I
don't give investment advice
you know almost all people that have
succeeded in new businesses were thought
to be fools at some point many people
who proposed new businesses are fools so
the trick is finding out which ones
aren't
[Music]
you know it's is there anyone out there
that is going to make millions or
billions of dollars in an innovative new
space based business in the next 10
years
I'm skeptical next 25 sure 10 I mean
tens pretty short for this business but
25 is not sure of the question are they
for real as they among the scientific
board of one of these companies they're
for real these are real by real these
are people investing money who come
largely out of the travel business and
not out of the space business and they
are convinced that the field of
adventure travel is such that there's an
Apple market for people who will take
short trips in space from suborbital up
to three orbits and pay for it less than
people pay to get carried up Mount
Everest which is to say of the order of
$50,000 well the one company is taking
reservations is charging 98k between
Fitz
they really estimate the main orders of
magnitude is between 10,000 and 100,000
but there are three companies now who
are in the business one taking
reservations and I think it's real oh
yeah I mean I believe Wilson will see
them and sooner than you might think
within less than a decade you know
people who you wouldn't associate with
well this is MIT geeks are all right up
here right or something some of the time
I mean you know it may be people who are
not socially acceptable smooth salesmen
but have creative ideas and the
willpower to see them through that will
do this so depends on your definition of
real sir I'd like to move to the space
science stuff that you addressed
obviously Dan Gulden's had a huge effect
on getting the space science program
moving a little west Huntersville and
endless but I get the impression that he
still suffers from the the other old
NASA disease which is once itself the
pad we don't care about it anymore that
the amount of resources into follow-up
data analysis and so on compared to
let's get another mission going is
there's still some issues there what
would you comment on that and I'd also
like as a follow-up to say what about
what do you think the impact has been of
the discovery in new millennium programs
in terms of there's been some criticism
of Pathfinder not really delivering a
lot of science maybe that's okay those
are all better questions than I have
answers I'm not really if you ask me
what the data analysis budget was within
the NASA space science I couldn't give
you a reasonable answer I am told I
think that that OMB put a reasonable
amount in the fiscal 99 budget request
the recognizing precisely the the
syndrome you're talking about that
is a recognition that that doing
something with the data plus putting it
on internet and slowing down the
proprietary control by the principle
investigators are not slowing down I
mean loosening it up all of that is I
think going on one of the graduates I'm
how many of you were undergraduates we
run a program in science technology and
space policy at my University which
likes to have graduates digits asked
that's why I go back there she tell you
about the experience anyway one of our
recent graduates is now the OMB budget
examiner for the Space Science program
and he carries an astrophysics degree
from Harvard into that so he knows what
he's doing anyway I don't know whether
he's gotten the bean counter mentality
totally in fact I know he hasn't no I
understand that well but it's related
exactly to your second question nobody
pays attention to data analysis and when
you launch a technology demonstration
mission that gets criticized because it
doesn't do much science I mean that the
whole expectation is all of this is
somehow only about science and and you
know the scientists have taken the lead
in creating that expectation that if it
ain't science it ain't worth doing how
much science is John Glenn going to do
for example so you know it's yeah
it's not a neat rational close in world
there is an overhead cost to the public
support of space science at depending on
how you want to count four or five
billion dollars a year combined Earth
and space science that's a lot of money
and to pay a little price for public
support and understanding it's not bad I
have a question for the driving forces
for the human settlement outside of
Earth you mentioned two criteria one
being you know can we use
extraterrestrial resources and second
it's their economic value that can be
created by it my question is related to
a third one that I think might might or
might not be a driver in the future I
looked at a chart of the evolution of
the world population recently and it's
really stunning what has happened in the
last hundred hundred and fifty years you
know how stable the world's population
was throughout the Antique in the Middle
Ages and how it's just exponentially
been shooting up in the last decades do
you think that that could be a potential
driver for I mean I'm not talking twenty
or thirty years I'm talking longer into
the future could that be a driver
could it be sure how likely is it they
drive around this country and say is it
what would it be easier to terraform the
Western Desert or Mars for example I
mean make more habitable land on this
planet compared to creating the
environment for space you know for human
settlement on other planets I don't
think that's going to be a driver maybe
species survival will be in human
curiosity and and just an impulse this
mckirdy quote I had at the start his
book is about the character of this
vision and the drivers of this vision of
human exploration and settlement and he
argues that it's rather peculiarly
American
and in some degree or at least Northern
European American and in some ways a
product mainly of the post-war period
not something he kind of tries to debunk
the whole frontier myth in American
history and the notion that space is the
next American frontier and you can argue
I think he overstates his argument but
let me just ask if what your assessment
is that the probability of a human Mars
mission being decided upon within 25
years decided upon that is a positive
decision - not launched but decided if I
engaged in a interesting discussion
Monday with with people in the executive
office of the president who are
beginning to think if a president wants
to do either this one or the next one
wants to make a major space decision is
there any alternative to humans for Mars
or is is that the only thing on on the
decision plate they don't want it to be
they don't they don't like the idea of a
single option being presented to any any
decision maker there is a strength of
conviction among a lot of people in our
business that it's Mars or nothing
timeframe timeframe timeframe 25 years
I'm willing to bet since I won't be here
to collect well I might be that that the
initial decision to start an
international expedition to Mars will
have been taken yeah
I have a question a comment on the space
tourism whether that's real or not it's
definitely true that they're booking
that the Stanford tourist agency its
booking for $90,000 if you look a little
bit behind we're actually the center
here is intimate with the company that's
promising to do that if you look at that
there's there's for marketers two
lawyers and two engineers and they're
going to do for $500,000 which is my
related question with the with the large
growth is in space that you see I mean
that the curves are just going off the
chart
how is the government gonna deal with
you know this doesn't really seem
feasible and I'm actually thinking about
in terms of bandwidth because you have
to get licenses you know you have to go
through this agency currently and you
know if everyone and their their brother
is starting to ask for we need this
bandwidth we need this this frequency
what's gonna happen what's what are we
gonna do short term to fix that problem
the question you asked didn't quite
match where I thought you were going so
let me answer both or I thought you were
going in the question the UAS even I
thought you were going to talk about
licensing of human travel to a private
travel to and from orbit which is not a
bandwidth issue as much as it is his
human safety and reentry and all that
sort of thing the commercial space Act
which is Massoud of committee in both
the House and Senate hasn't been passed
by the Senate yet has the initial
provisions to begin to license reentry
systems which we have to do before X 33
or at least anything that would follow
it or Kistler for that matter and that's
one of the reasons I kiss lived in
Kessler aerospace is the seattle-based
startup that that claims to be starting
as flights they later this year but
they're starting their flights out of
Australia rumor because of all there's
no licensing authority in the United
States for it yeah so there's I mean
there's a general comment which which
relates to all part of your questions
which is the role
as these private sector uses of space
expand will have to include regulatory
as well as our Indy support creating
regulatory regimes rules for these new
sectors of activity and in particular
the the international body that
allocates frequencies which is the
International Telecommunications Union
is widely viewed as broken and and not
the right the way it does business not
the right way to make intelligent
decisions on this extremely scarce an
extremely valuable resource so I think
that's an issue that that leaders around
the world concerned with us are
beginning to address the next world
radio conference is 99 and it's supposed
to be the frequencies for long-term GPS
for example how would that that body
differentiate the the you know the the
good stuff from the bad stuff the real
stuff three engineers or do you have to
come from respectable company I mean
what's that what's the criteria I don't
know it well enough to give you a full
answer and the full answer would take a
long time basically though it's a bunch
of delegations of countries that come
together and vote as one country so
there is some thought that the less than
reputable places become higher on the
representative of Ghana or what country
I can insult that way you know to carry
their interest rather than fight within
the United States to get their interest
advanced the international politics that
that is an interesting question yes I
had a question on the learning from
Space Station and I'm wondering how much
is being learned from Mir and how much
that's modified the way we plan doing
Space Station
you're asking me are you asking Larry
I'm asking in general I can I can tell
you what I've been told about that by
some people who I trust which is that
the main thing we've learned from Mir is
the way to do work in space
long-duration work the kind of
preparations the value of redundancy the
ability to have flexibility in your work
schedules the the type of crew training
and procedures rather than any of the
science clause science and you might
want to add to that I'm afraid that I've
had had relatively similar feedback
which which is not very much new hard
science with respect to humans living in
space not tremendous surprises that not
much data but an enormous amount of
experience related to how to solve
problems in long-duration weightlessness
and something that Chuck omen has
brought to our attention that there's a
big difference between two weeks and two
months in space and there becomes a
period in which it's in which the
psychological reactions to living up
there for a long while because become
dominant yeah what comment about shuttle
just being a camping trip you can you
can get along with people you know if
you know it's a short time but you if
you're there for a long time you either
get along or you have the experience
that the biosphere 2 had of splitting
the warring camps which would not be
good along the way to Mars now we have
people in the Center for Space Research
who have had beer experience any
comments for us perhaps one last
question we will let dr. Logsdon yeah
you've had one doctors talk Llosa yeah
yes John talking about station again I
think you you had a comment when you
were talking about humans in space and
you said we have to do station before we
do anything else did you mean that from
a political standpoint or from a Mission
Operations standpoint political I think
the in the
a plan that's been laid out for how one
does space 50 years ago already
I got short-circuited by Apollo by a
political decision to go to to do to go
to the moon but the notion that there
are more compelling scientific or other
reasons to go send people far away from
the earth without first finding out what
they can do near the earth just it goes
against common sense that that that that
so there is a technical justification to
it that before we go venturing out
across the seas we ought to find out
what humans living working in a
well-equipped laboratory in the space
environment can actually do hopefully we
will let me ask the students who are
members of the course of modern space
sciences and engineering to join us in
the back have a have some cookies and
then we'll have an informal discussion
with dr. Logsdon you can also hand in
your assignments that are due to better
do today all the rest of you thank you
for for joining us and John thank you
for an outstanding lecture
[Applause]